George Wald is a member of a minority
group now you couldn't tell by looking
and it's not the fact that he's a Nobel
Prize winner in medicine and physiology
no it's George unlike his fellow
scientists or most of his fellow
scientists who buried their paradise
heads in the sands of academia or cuddle
closely and comfortably with their
corporate controllers George actively is
struggling against the problems which
beset the world these awesome problems
which require immediate attention he's
associated with a committee for nuclear
responsibility for the Union of
Concerned Scientists he attends many of
the anti-nuclear rallies around the
country around the world and he's in
Austin giving a speech for the
mobilization for survival George is the
title of your speech is survival in a
lethal Society is it really lethal you
know today I came out here and the birds
were singing and the bees were making
love and the Sun was nice what's the
silly thing about it's lethal on the
grand scale and in those nice words you
just said about me you introduced the
problem to the problem whether I'm
talking outside my field that seems to
consent people very much very much more
than it does me now I'm talking in my
field because my field is life I'm a
biologist and life is threatened as
never before in the history of this
planet and some of the threats work
slowly and one threat could finish the
job in half an hour and that's half
hours interchange the present nuclear
stockpiles of the United States and the
Soviet Union that would be curtains for
the human race and much of the rest of
life on this planet so that's what
brings me out it's a concern for life
and I think it's enough he'll fight but
I am a happy person happy doomed talker
one of my friends called me a doom Cup
yes and the only thing that keeps me
happy is that I struggle I'm angry I'm
as angry as can be and that's what keeps
me happy I've read some scientists or
some people say that actually it's too
late right now I think any sensible
person would say that would see and say
and realize that the chances of survival
not all that great and at the moment
seemed to be growing less rapidly I feel
as though I were moving through a
fantasy world as though you know when we
run an express train to disaster with
with no engineer
it's absolutely mad and right now all
you have to do is pick up any newspaper
and you find that the great American
indoor sport at the top don't know why I
call it indoors it's outdoors at the
very top very top of government is
twisting the tale of the Russian bear
bear doesn't have much of a tail and I
guess consequently it it's mighty
painful when it's twisted but that's
what's happening absolutely mad to
provoke you know everything seems to be
being done to to provoke trouble
George you mentioned the recent flap
between the United States and Russia and
for certainly the media have given a lot
of attention but actually preoccupied
with that issue
but there does manage to pierce that
trivia nightly stories about the
contamination of our environment dioxin
keep on vinyl chloride asbestos I'd I
best asbestos ad nauseam I don't want to
ask you are the media asking the right
questions about the lethal Society and
what should be done about it
all are we documenting the symptoms
rather than the causes evidence of
chemical pollution continues to spread
across the Lamb a state official says it
is so widespread and pervasive in
Michigan that we can't afford to clean
it up Smith lives in the area east of
Los Angeles where the smog is the worst
on clear days he enjoys moderate
exercise but this week he has not been
able to even walk to the mailbox without
his oxygen tank
some time ago a substance that causes
cancer in laboratory animals was
identified in bacon
it is nitrosamine now comes a Public
Interest science group that says beer
drinkers are getting a lot more
nitrosomonas than bacon eaters since DDT
and similar compounds were banned
because of the threat to the environment
they have been replaced by many more
dangerous pesticides more poisonous to
humans some are known to cause cancer
genetic damage and birth defects in
animals because of that some scientists
say that the greatest danger might not
show up at once
Agriculture Department official said
today the PCB toxic chemicals suspected
of causing cancer has turned up in food
and animal feed
in 17 states from Oregon to New Jersey
the Department spokesman said people
aren't in immediate danger but there is
a crash program to recall thousands of
pounds of contaminated poultry pork and
egg products the contamination came from
a single packing plant in Billings
Montana and a Senate subcommittee
revealed that highly radioactive water
is still pouring from damaged areas of
the stricken Three Mile Island atomic
plant the leak can't be stopped for more
than a year probably the plants running
out of places to put the contaminated
water the problem is an urgent one and
none of the suggested solutions has even
been tried meanwhile the committee
members said there was a danger of
seepage of the water to the outside
environment that plant is on the
Susquehanna River which feeds into
Chesapeake Bay I think the sickness in
the whole situation is in the myth that
government and even industry said about
rationally to do the things that will
most benefit society that's just crazy
that's not the world in which we live
the power industry isn't there to make
power it's to make money the arms
industry isn't there to promote our
national security it's to make money
every industry turned to is engaged in
just one dominant Enterprise and that is
to make money and not just to make that
much money it's to make as much as can
possibly be made at any cost and human
health human life security whatever you
like
George publicity over the hazardous
waste dumps such as The Love Canal in
Niagara Falls has apparently led the
chemical industry to launch a campaign
to clean up its image what do you
what's your response to ads like the
Monsanto ad that says without chemicals
life itself would be impossible in your
windshield is an invisible chemical
called polyvinyl butyl
this chemical made by Monsanto could
save your life
in an accident no chemical is totally
safe all the time everywhere but to make
driving safer
we need chemicals like polyvinyl guter
all that's why every new car sold in
America has a laminated safety glass
windshield without chemicals life itself
would be impossible that's about the
most the most inane comment on a really
serious situation that I can imagine I
don't know
how foolish they think American public
is at least that part of it that knows
how to read your molecules are alright
we're made of molecules but we're not
made of those molecules now the chemical
industry which is willing to spend large
sums of money in the conviction at the
public is as dumb as can be you know and
will take anything that's said to be
expert and that has a little technical
vocabulary in it
Dow Chemical Corporation for example you
mentioned Love Canal the problem in Love
Canal is dioxin which is one of the most
toxic substances known well Dow has been
in a campaign to show that dioxin isn't
an industrial waste necessarily or even
regularly it's just a product of
combustion people burning garbage
anywhere out comes dioxin they say I
don't believe a word of it but that's
Dow at work now you have this an named
story from Monsanto so let me say a few
words about Monsanto Monsanto my
institution Harvard University Monsanto
and Dow Harvard Medical School
I think primarily the public health
school at Harvard Medical School with 12
million dollars with some strings
attached that are kind of interesting
but anyhow twelve million dollars that
made Harvard very happy but you know
Monsanto varies its business and
Monsanto makes the dito Nader's four
hydrogen bombs it does that at a place
called the mound laboratories near
Dayton Ohio and I enjoy that you know
public health and hydrogen bombs
that's Monsanto for you so I think that
the story is what I just said
and the rules that are emerging is
beware of smokes and dusts you shouldn't
be inhaling any of that that you can
avoid and that includes smoking and the
other rule that's emerging very strongly
another rule is to avoid chlorinated
hydrocarbons PCBs are chlorinated
hydrocarbons almost every Gloria
chloroform almost any chlorinated
organic chemical and let me just say as
a biochemist chlorine does not appear
you know they're talking the body as
chemicals yes indeed chlorine to my
knowledge does not appear in any living
organism on this planet and yet it
appears in innumerable organic chemicals
used in made by sold by industry George
our science was never a strong suit of
mine but maybe you can cut through some
of the rhetoric here they argue that
some people think anything chemical is
bad and anything natural is good yet
nature is chemical are they telling the
full story art that isn't the
petrochemical industry since the
war world war ii era producing chemicals
that have never yet been never before
been produced on the planet and don't
they pose a health hazard yes of course
and I would say that though petroleum is
natural I wouldn't be so foolish as to
either either drink eat or inhale
petroleum or any fraction of petroleum I
mean this is just utter nonsense so yes
indeed there are both natural molecules
that are things to keep away from and
there are a host and growing hosts of
synthetic products which don't appear in
living organisms at all in fact you know
you want to kill a living organism as
people want to kill molds as people want
to kill insects as people want to kill
corn borers as people want to kill
bacteria various kinds you get yourself
an organic molecule that those things
can't live with so this is just utterly
a name and any child knows better only
problem with Kim can't cancer though in
the kind of diseases we're talking about
it's not like an oncoming train it's
latency period is 25 or 30 years and
they can mask essentially the poisonous
aspect out the dreadful thing you can
live a long time with that cancer
getting ready and yes it can go up to 30
years sometimes perhaps even longer you
see we're in a desperate situation let
me talk nuclear weapons for a moment
nuclear weapons you see
in fact all the weapons the arms
procurement budget the American arms
procurement budget all through the
Vietnam War hovered around twenty four
billion dollars twenty four billion
dollars now the great amount that were
told at the Defense Department is to use
forty billion dollars and when a thing
like Seoul to comes up the
administration is actually just in so
many words naked Lee being held for
ransom being told by certain senators he
you increase that already swollen arms
procurement budget by several billion
dollars a year or you don't get salt too
and it looks as though we will have to
purchase arms control by increasing our
arms but that's nothing new actually the
present stockpiles in the United States
and the Soviet Union of just the
strategic nuclear weapons that's the big
stuff those present stockpiles add up to
sixteen billion tons of TNT the
explosive equivalent of sixteen billion
tons of TNT we're four billion people on
the earth so that means four tons of TNT
for every man woman and child in the
earth that's just the strategic stuff in
addition each side US and the Soviet
Union have tens of thousands of
so-called tactical nuclear weapons I bet
it and incidentally already stockpiled
the material to make hundreds of
thousands more so I better tell you what
a tactical nuclear weapon is I was a
member I was the American member of an
international commission that in August
1977 sat down with all the available
good data to decide what had happened as
an aftermath as a result of the
atom bombs that we dropped on Hiroshima
Nagasaki the bomb that we dropped on
Hiroshima and that just level that city
wiped it out in a moment and by the end
of that year in 1945 had killed 140,000
people that was a miserably small
trivial 12.5 kiloton weapon a tactical
nuclear weapon much too small to be
counted in the salt talks so that's the
situation now facing that situation you
know with all that overkill with the
with we able to to wipe out with nuclear
weapons every city in the Soviet Union
of over a hundred thousand forty times
over and they able to wipe out every
city in the United States of over a
hundred thousand twenty times over with
that the present situation we are making
three hydrogen warheads per day and have
been making them at that great for at
least the last seven years so you know
is this insane yes it's insane unless
one holds an arms contract and then it's
business and bigger the better
George even if we are able to avoid
nuclear catastrophe we're still able to
all be zapped by radiation by chemicals
yet we have at least a phoner so I say
we have unleashed upon ourselves but the
corporate structure and the government
and see I personally and I'll be talking
about that tonight here I think that the
reality is that that Industrial
Revolution that just started 200 years
ago in two hundred years is nothing in
human history and still less in
geological history in 200 years the
Industrial Revolution has brought the
human race to the brink of self
extinction
it turned lethal that's the reason for
the title of my talk
it turned lethal on the grand scale some
years
and it doesn't just involve nuclear
weapons and other weapons of mass
destruction having said what I did about
nuclear weapons the business of making
other so-called conventional weapons in
this country is three times as big as
the business of making the nuclear
weapons nuclear weapons business is
worth about 10 billions a year and the
conventional weapons another 30 billions
and I have done the opposite of
exaggerating
I have understated the costs and the
situation killing and destruction is now
the biggest business in the world
worldwide last year we don't have a hard
figure as yet but well over 400 billion
dollars spent on military things
worldwide in the past year but it isn't
just that industrial disease seventy to
ninety percent so eighty percent is a
fair figure of all the cancer in the
United States is it environmentally
urgent and hence preventable we keep
being told about crash programs to find
cures for cancer much more than cures
the war on cancer there's much more than
cures we just need to cancer from
happening the really big job would be to
stop those and dust those those
environmental cancers and of the 80%
that is environmental roughly forty
percent so roughly one-third of all the
cancers in the United States happen in
the workplaces of course denied by
industry I've been watching this
situation for many years
and I have yet to know an instance in
which the industry fails to fight tooth
and nail any attempt to clean up the
shops to establish standards to get
proper medical records it just fights
all along the way when everything else
fails it goes into court just as a
delaying procedure
the point is that any attempt to get at
this situation increases production
costs and increases liability costs
insurance costs workman's compensation
costs so the business of the physicians
attached to all big industry is to save
money for the industry their clients are
not the workers their clients
corporation well Jorge let me see if I
can draw into sharp focus the basic
choices which you think confront us here
and trying to transform the lethal
society into a healthy society what are
the impediments you've obviously are no
friend of business what are the
impediments business and otherwise would
stand in the way of attaining a healthy
society let me say something cheerful
you know in my kind of circles perhaps
in yours the cure for every problem is
do research you know do research
eventually get out of report well
research is fine it's great we never
know enough about anything but it must
not be used as it constantly is used now
as a excuse for the for forever
deferring action and I want to say
something cheerful we already know
enough to begin to cope with all those
multiple threats to life human life on
our planet but there isn't one of them
that we can begin to cope with while
maximizing profits and I think that
that's the bugbear so you would see the
market system then is incompatible with
a healthy society but I'm trying I would
want to emphasize that cheerful note the
answers to what are presented to us as
insoluble problems are as plain and
simple and easy for the most part is
falling off a log but for that very
reason
won't be taken what are they well made
me a problem and I'll give you the
answer as best I got it my garlic and I
really do that let's try it cancer in
the workplace cancer in the workplace
clean up the shops there's no great
problem there the shops need to be
cleaned up and properly monitored and
the permissible limits we have them for
radiation radioactive heat those
permissible limits are all purely
arbitrary compromises between the
demands of industry and their lobbies
and the realities on radiation and I'm
talking specifically high-energy
radiation so-called ionizing radiation I
like to say it this way every dose is an
overdose there is no permissible limit a
little does harm more does more harm and
then most of these things that are
killing workers and producing industrial
disease in the workplaces the limits
need to be the shops need to be cleaned
up and the limits need to be brought
down and bringing those limits down and
the present circumstances is something
that is fought by the industrial lobbies
by industry by those sections of
government that are dominated by
industry and if all else fails brought
into the courts just to delay what
government would claim that they're in a
crossfire between inflationary pressures
the kinds of changes that you would you
advocate for the workplace would cause
an unfair hardship a burden on them that
would put them at a competitive
disadvantage with other finding other
industries you know there's a knee-jerk
reflex at work in this situation on the
corporate side and that has been mediate
cry workers will lose their jobs to here
industry when it's asked to clean up a
shop or to do anything else that will
save health and life you would think
that the industry was in business only
to provide jobs to workers and sometimes
the workers are so foolish as to
actually resist the cleaning up at the
shops for fear that they might lose
their jobs and you know a sad truth you
put any worker between his job and
perhaps the threat of loss of his life
he'll take the job and let fate take
care of his life he'll take the job
before any other consideration so what
we meet is to clean up the shops and
assure the work is that they will not
lose their jobs I think that coupled
with many of the other things that I'm
all for and go around talking for we
have to couple with those things
the politics of full employment that's
very important a George we're talking
about and I agree with you when you say
that a lot of these things are a result
of the marketplace and a profit and yet
we find that the Soviet Union the Cuba
and the socialist countries also are
doing the same thing not to the great
extent and not to the great abusive
extent that they are in the United
States and the Western capitalist world
but they're heavy pro-nuke errs is there
something deeper is there some type of a
preoccupation with technology itself is
something automatically good no matter
what you come out fishin see regardless
of profits I've thought about this a
great deal and I'll tell you where I
come out I think that any society that
puts production the maximization of
production as its dominant gain ends up
not very different from one that's
pursuing the maximization of profit I
think there is if an in reality no
nation that is closely resembles the
United States as the Soviet you
and yes you are quite right in that
pursuit of maximizing production they
give the health of the workers their
welfare frequently short shrift and I
have encountered in just in Japan last
August I was in an international meeting
that had Soviet and a cuban
representation we had a meeting in fact
i had more or less force decision on
nuclear power and everybody present was
against nuclear power the only ones who
spoke for it at all were soviet union
representative anna cuban representative
but to my surprise and i was glad of
that both of them spoke very softly
indeed very circumspectly and i just
read in the new york times the other day
that a first criticism by an economist
and a nuclear engineer had appeared in a
top soviet publication criticism of the
dangers in nuclear power so I think the
Soviet Union is being forced to realize
this is dangerous business I'm talking
now nuclear power and in fact we have
rather credible reports that the
greatest nuclear catastrophe that has
yet happened happened in the fifties in
the Urals in the Soviet Union and
devastated a large area George there are
some people who say well Homo Sapien
mankind is fatally flawed and we won't
be able to make it that the life-support
system is too delicate to be able to
handle this bludgeoning which we have
given it do you think that we are sowing
the seeds of destruction and if so are
we capable of coming out of it
yes we are sowing the seeds of
destruction but the world is full of
especially after you left this country
and I've been over most of the world
during the last year the world is full
of decent generous hard-working people
who are open not aggressive not very
competitive who want a chance to live
decently you know and buy decently I
don't mean without working and I don't
mean a plush standard of living I mean
just have adequate clothing be able to
feed their kids be able to find some
sort of medical help when they need it
have shelter and education as a real
hunger for education I find wherever I
go and I've been pretty much all over
the world now seek out the backcountry
whenever I can
the world is full of decent people and
tell you some funny things you know you
were asking you know solutions simple
solutions D realize that we're growing
now in the world much more than enough
grain adequately to feed all the people
in the world and yet about two-thirds of
the world's people regularly go hungry
and a lot of them starve what's
happening to that grain well when you
ask and set in seconds your Torah is a
distribution problem the other is a
distribution problem food goes only
where it can go at a profit where you
can sell it at a profit no profit no
distribution second point the world is
now filled with people my authority for
this is that well-known radical Robert
McNamara explored company executive X
Secretary of Defense kicked upstairs by
your fellow Texan LBJ to be the
president
the World Bank which is what he is now
he shouts about people in the world who
are not just unemployed but for whom
there's no further use in a market
economy one wishes they weren't there
and because the world is increasingly
filled with people who who who are not
in any position to buy food at what will
be a profit to the people who supply it
there is a new game of food and it's
brand new increasing at explosive speed
in fact the whole thing has happened
only in the last 10 to 15 years and that
is a fantastic explosive increase in the
demand for meat particularly beef in all
the developed world and the more
affluent portions of the underdeveloped
world eating beef has become the symbol
the index of the standard of living now
all over the world and it takes 8 pounds
of grain to produce 1 pound of meat and
feeding me to the affluent is a
profitable business and that's where the
grain is going the grain that could be
feeding hungry peasant workers
unemployed is going instead to feed
cattle and pigs and chickens to supply
this
explosively growing demand for me so I'm
saying to you the answers to these
problems that are so life-threatening
all over the world are very simple but
they don't go together either with a
dominantly profit-maximizing or a
dominantly production maximizing
situation Georgia does seem does come
down some basic questions of philosophy
do you think that the demands for
alternative technologies and alternative
energies really constitute a demand for
alternative society one that questions
the values of possessive individualism
and profit and competition and instead
has a vision of a cooperative more
communal way of Lajos sure that's right
I think what we need is not to maximize
profit or to maximize production but to
maximize a decent life for people and
there you know people regularly when
they feel threatened or when they feel
pressed produce very mean feelings about
about grownups but I think the essence
of the whole situation as the children
you can't feel all that mean about kids
you can't feel threatened by kids kids
are in our care or kids my kids your
kids everybody's kids and it's they who
suffer first and most when there are
shortages it's the kids
who are the first to suffer and I think
that that you know
one of the crazy one of the crazy
paradoxes of American life right now is
the right to life movement the right to
embryonic life
I'll go right down the line with those
people who want to take such good care
of human fetuses if they'll only join me
in taking care of children already born
what we do to kids in this country and
in this world justice after disgrace so
let's try and save the kids who have
been born and then I'll go on and worry
about the fetuses George you're
wonderful I wish we could stay here and
talk for hours that we must share you
with other people here in Austin I know
you have a very busy schedule and good
luck glad to have been with you thank
you for coming thank you and George Walt
I hope that your next Nobel Prize will
be the Nobel Peace Prize I'd love that